bonjour à toutes et à tous l'invité de
saint roch a dit ce matin jaunies ajar
bonjour bonjour bonjour à toute la
martinique vous êtes le secrétaire
général de l'upm fraîchement réélu lors
du congrès qui s'est tenu ce week end
johnny jarry un problème avec la
sénatrice catherine conconne johnny
jarre a fait attendre de d'éveil deux
minutes de discours et pas une seule
fois vous l'avez mentionné le nom de la
sénatrice même pas leur dire merci non
j'ai écouté bien il ya aucun problème
avec la sénatrice catherine conconne est
une militante du parti progressiste
martiniquais qui a d'ailleurs été
désigné par le parti progressiste
antennes et qu'elle n'aime pas mon ombre
bien sûr je tiens d'abord à remercier
l'ensemble des militants qui ont
organisé pendant trois jours le congrès
le 21ème congrès du parti progressiste
martiniquais
je rappelle que parti progressiste à 65
et aujourd'hui le socle qui a permis à
ce que ce congrès et ses militants
puissent travailler en toute visibilité
c'est justement la question de l'unité
de du rassemblement face aux enjeux et
défis à relever pour la martinique
c'est un oubli volontaire je le répète
vous insister sur un point qui pour moi
n'a pas d'intérêt puisque aujourd'hui le
ppm me xavier dernier vous n'avez pas
répondu
vous n'avez pas léger parfaitement
répondu nous avons travaillé ensemble
j'ai salué puisque je rappelle que nous
allons aux élections municipales
je salue et de l'ensemble des membres
ont leurs grades et qualités notamment
les élus maires qui sont candidats
d'ailleurs et vous veut peut-être même
dire que j'ai oublié de saluer les
candidats investis par le bpm aux
municipales mais effectivement il faut
avoir ce regard lucide
ce qui importe ce ne sont pas les hommes
et les femmes ce sont les idées les
valeurs que nous portons donc
l'important c'est que ce 21ème congrès
lance un message à la martinique
un cap et une possibilité pour donner
une espérance nouvelle en revanche que
vous avez bien déclaré que avec force
lors de votre discours que serge
letchimy et est votre candidat pour 2021
ce que vous faites et que vous feriez
tout
pour qui soit élue miss âge à l'adresse
de quelqu un message adressé à quelque 3
particulier qui vous aurez envie de
monter une liste dont sein de votre
parti
alors pas du tout il faut bien mesurer
la portée des propos il ya un congrès
tous les militants trulli
toutes les personnalités et les
fonctions important le président
secrétaire général comité national sont
tombés on est redevenus des simples
militants pendant trois jours au bout de
ces trois jouent là il ya une réélection
pour la direction du parti la présidence
du parti
mais il faut aussi donner un cap pour
que le message soit clair vis-à-vis de
nos militants nous sympathisants et tous
les martiniquais toutes les matinées
qu'est-ce qui nous suivent
personnellement je suis engagée autour
de siège de chimie pas la personne
simplement
mais le visionner en le penseur qui a
cette capacité de pouvoir se sublimer se
transcender et nous permettent d'avancer
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce pays étant en
panne il a besoin d'être redressé la
dignité humaine vous retrouver son sens
et si je les nommer c'est parce que je
considère moi personnellement et j'ai
bien insisté en disant personnellement
puisque le comité national suivra son
cours et je sais que la personne
elle-même de siège de chimie décidera si
oui ou non et ça c'est son choix
néanmoins moi en tant que secrétaire
général nouvellement élu j'ai le droit
de donner ma pensée et je pense que
c'est le seul capable de redresser ce
pays aujourd'hui au niveau de la
martinique de donner une espérance
nouvelle dans le respect des valeurs
citoyennes et de l'idéologie autonomie
scars equities travaillé pendant ce
temps donc c'est bien ce que je vous
disais c'est pour faire arrêter toutes
les velléités pas de 2 tentation de deux
listes qui pourrait se monter qu'ils
avaient envie de se monter au sein de
votre parti
alors je le répète mais vous êtes sudic
des les ambitions personnelles peut-être
chacun est libre de pouvoir porter une
liste mais il ya une organisation et un
comité d'investiture
d'accord il ya un comité national
nouvellement élu vous avez dû voir qu'il
ya beaucoup de jeunes et la parité
obligatoire puisqu'il ya quinze femmes
15 hommes qui ont été présentés hier à
l'issue du congrès et je le répète et
j'insiste à votre attention
l'idée n'est pas de parler du ppm en
interne mais c'est le message parce que
le bbm et up party peau
éthique quel message nous donnons à la
martinique où sortir de ce 21ème congrès
moi aujourd'hui le message que je veux
lancer ce qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité
c'est que les solutions sont en nous
mêmes et que malgré les difficultés qui
se posent à nous au quotidien et qui
vont continuer à se poser dans les
années futures
eh bien il faut donner de
l'investissement faut donner du sens
faut donner de la dignité humaine
et ce combat là à travers un projet à
travers une idéologie une armature
idéologique que nous devons positionner
éduquer mettre en accessibilité à tous
les martiniquaises et martiniquais doit
se faire tous d'hommes et de femmes et
aux amis lancé vous avez relancé
justement le vôtre mot d'ordre
d'autonomie
est-ce que la martinique aujourd'hui a
besoin de nouveaux débats
institutionnels et goûter vous pouvez le
traduit sous forme institutionnelle mais
nous avons surtout besoin de prendre en
compte nos réalités et donc permettre
aux élus martiniquais d'avoir des
responsabilités parce que ne l'ont pas
déjà une manière titution cas de manière
est ce qu on l a déjà épuisé le tour de
la séquence qui l'a fait déjà le tour
quand vous avez des compétences en
moyens vous n'avez pas le pouvoir
quand vous avez la possibilité d'adapter
sans pouvoir légiférer décidé au niveau
de la loi et du règlement du cadre dans
lequel vous voulez que la martinique
puisse développer ses activités son
économie sont sociales sont transporte
le vol environnementales écologiques
ce n'est pas possible de lever les
habilitations ch ont étudié et travaillé
aujourd'hui mais est-ce que les avez les
habilitations suffisent on voit bien que
non parce qu'aujourd'hui si le
martiniquais n'est pas capables de
penser par lui-même et attend
automatiquement les solutions qui
doivent venir d'ailleurs on voit bien
qu'ils diminuent show d'état ou des
dotations d'état aujourd'hui collecter
les collectivités sont livrée à elle
même les maires aujourd'hui népal n'ont
pas les moyens de mettre en place une
politique publique
si on crée pas de richesses et pour
créer des richesses il faut avoir des
leviers
elle vient jouer je le répète
l'autonomie n'est pas la séparation
parce qu'il faut le dire très clairement
ça a été répété ce n'est pas le
séparatisme oui on est français saisir
le dit très bien ses alliés le double
souci à la fois d'être français mais
aussi des martiniquais c'est à dire de
prendre nos réalités locales matinée
seconde journée on a fait le tour de la
question par exemple de la 7e semaine à
peine cinq ans d'existence et vous êtes
en train des jarres vous devoir relancer
le débat
alors qu'on appelle peut-être pas épuisé
tous
tous les pouvoirs possible toutes les
possibilités que deux coffres là c'était
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique est une institution c'est un
moyen dingo ce n'est pas une fin en soi
ce qu'il faut c'est mettre en place tous
les outils comme la collectivité
territoriale de martinique qui simplifie
puisqu'il rassemble à la fois les
compétences du conseil général et le
conseil régional mais aussi de me donner
la capacité de mettre en place nos
politiques publiques
mais si on n'a pas à travers les
habilitations mais aussi plus largement
parce que les habilitations sont donnés
dans un cadre donné je suis une donnée
sur un temps limité et elles ne sont pas
transversale
il n'ya pas d'habilitation globale et
avec d'habilitation dans un domaine
particulier aux quand vous mettez en
place une politique publique qu'elles
soient du transport eh bien elle ne
touche pas que le transport et touche
l'économie elle touche le social touche
des domaines
nous n'avons pas ces habilitations
aujourd'hui dans le cadre dans lequel
nous sommes qui nous permettent de
mettre en place un livret politique
parce que décidé est une chose mettre en
oeuvre en est une autre et si nous
n'avons pas ce pouvoir législatif et
réglementaire
voici un exemple de différenciation
notre mieux à vos besoins parce que
l'autonomie c'est ça s'est associé le
droit à l'égalité
donc les conquêtes sociales et autres
qui sont intéressantes puisque nous
sommes français mais aussi le droit à la
différence
la loi sous la division de la chimie
voilà un exemple parce que c'est une loi
qui ne s'applique que pour les outre-mer
donc elle doit pouvoir s'appliquer aux
outre-mer par rapport à nos réalités
donc ça aujourd'hui c'est faisable mais
ça a été un long combat ça a pris
énormément de temps
mais dans tous ces domaines comme sur la
division comme sur les permis de
construire comme sur l'environnement
comme sur l'urbanisme les maires
aujourd'hui la collectivité territoriale
de martinique doit pouvoir avoir les
moyens de mettre en oeuvre son projet
politique autre point de ce congrès
l'alliance elle s'est effritée et
beaucoup sont partis n'ont besoin ni son
parfum faut pas dire ça sur 12 en 3 se
retrouve à neuf donc si entre 12 et 9 6
a fait beaucoup je ne sais pas mais tout
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'il y
avait là le maire boucle ailleurs qui
sont partis non non non non pourtant pas
d'alliance sont pas le mouvement
politique qui se sont regroupés
l'assemblée on parle d'individus on
parle pas de fonction ce sont des partis
politiques des mouvements mais
représentent des musées un ami
je parle pas de parti moon ou communaux
qui n'existe qu'à travers une personne
non non pas du tout paris non pas du
tout non je peux pas le dire puisque
c'est le sénateur antiste et bien mpf il
permet donc ce que vous dites ne tient
pas la route
désolé je veux dire simplement sur
l'alliance et qu' il faut un socle
commun aujourd'hui une alliance un
rassemblement de mouvements mais sur
quelles bases
est-ce que c'est sur une base purement
électoraliste de postes et de pouvoir
non ça doit se faire sur une base
minimale d'abord idéologique
si vous voulez vous marier si vous
voulez vous rassembler il faut partager
un minimum de valeurs et d'idéologie
ensuite vous devez partager un projet et
c'est à partir de là donc oui le congrès
l'a dit l'alliance est utile le
rassemblement d'hommes et de femmes de
bonne volonté pour viol pays est utile
maintenant il faut des conditions de
construction de reconstruction de ses
talents et bien si cette alliance doit
se faire à 5 6 7 10 15
elle se fera mais il faut que ça soit
partagé notamment au niveau des valeurs
et c'est ça qui est fondamental ces
accords sont en partage l'autonomie
soignait ton sens de lannion pas du tout
pas du tout la question de l'autonomie
c'est la question de la responsabilité
est ce qu'on peut partager l'idée de la
responsabilité
chacun est libre parce que on peut pas
vouloir l'égalité des droits le droit à
la différence et de ne pas l'accepter
dans un cadre plus large qui le
rassemblement de l'alliance donc nous
aussi il y aura des concessions à faire
nous on ne peut pas mettre de notre
poche nôtre nous donne simplement parce
que certains ne sont pas d'accord
donc il ya un minimum et quand je parle
du socle idéologique 6 dans les tirs et
de la martinique puisque aujourd'hui on
voit bien que la martinique est en panne
que la martinique est à l'arrêt et que
ni l'état n'a aucune idée ni la
collectivité territoriale le fait
d'investissements au les problèmes
s'aggravent
il faut absolument agir pour maintenant
et pour l'avenir
donc ce combat là nous devons le prendre
en main c'est notre seule solution pour
permettre aux générations qui arrivent
et bien de pouvoir avoir un héritage
noble et positionne que mot sur les
municipales avant de clôturer cette
émission vous allez soutenir le ppm va
soutenir
le mur de cette marie par exemple
écouter aujourd'hui il ya une
organisation qui se met en place nous
avons investi un certain nombre de
candidats et nous avons soutenir certain
nombre de candidats il y a déjà des
demandes de soutien qui arrivent
d'autres communes dans ma vie qui serait
futile et nous n'avons alors le monde
dedans je n'avais pas encore reçu de
demande de soutien
nous ne sommes pas fermés aux hommes de
progrès parce que je rappelle que dans
l'idéologie pour mucistes autonomie s'il
ya la notion de progrès mais pas là pour
gosses à ce matériel le premier sens de
la dignité humaine
le pogo sens de l'âme le pogo sens des
valeurs et si ce travail là que nous
devons mener non plus chez marie c est
aujourd'hui nous voyons le travail qui
fait par le maire de sète mari
nous ne pouvons que regarder dans le
positionnement électorale actuelle se
met à se passer n'est avancée dans le
cadre de la direction du parti avec
l'organisation et l'ambiance mise par le
maire si jeune et hajar bonne journée
aller coûte de nouveaux programmes